Hello Freak bitches.
I mean it's,
who the hell doesn't want to hear that?
So we're treading kind of close to the,
uh,
the argument she got into with Sam
Harris about the nature of truth. And,
and since I heard that I've been sort of
itching to have this conversation with
you because I think there's a, uh, a
way of viewing this that will actually,
um,
perhaps reconcile the two points of view,
but there's a bitter pill that comes along
with it. So here's, here's my argument.
Um,
we tend to think of intellect has evolved,
has as having evolved because knowing
what's true gives you an advantage,
but there's actually nothing that says
that the literal truth is where advantage
lies. And so, uh, I have a category
that I call literally false,
metaphorically true. These are ideas
that aren't true in the factual sense,
but they are true enough that if
you behave as if they were true,
you come out ahead of where you would
be if you behaved according to the fact
that they're not true.
So let me give you a couple of trivial
examples that won't be controversial.
Porcupines can throw
their quills not true.
However,
if you live near porcupines and you
imagine that porcupines can throw their
quills, you'll give them
some space. If you don't,
you may realize and that they can't throw
their quills get really close to one
and it may wheel around and
nail you with a porcupine quill,
which can be extremely dangerous because
they are microscopically designed to
move in from where they puncture you
over time and they can puncture a vital
organ or you can get an infection.
So the person who believes that a
porcupine can throw their quills has an
advantage that isn't predicated on the
fact that this is actually a literal
truth, right? Um,
another one might be, uh,
people say everything happens
for a reason, right? Well,
unless you're talking about physics as
the reason everything doesn't happen for
a reason.
However,
if you are the kind of person who believes
that everything happens for a reason
and then some terrible tragedy befalls
you, you may be on the lookout. Well,
what's the reason that this happened?
Maybe it's supposed to open
some opportunity and you
won't miss that opportunity
the way somebody who was preoccupied
with their misfortune wood.
So literal falseness,
but metaphorical truth is actually I
would argue the category under which
religious truth evolves.
Now the problem,
the bitter pill that
I mentioned is that I,
I've heard you say that the
truths that are captured in the,
the religious version of
things are basically like, uh,
you know,
there's an individual truth and then
there's a truth of your family and it's a
truth of the population
that you're living in.
And these things are all encoded in these,
these doctrines,
which is true and you would expect it
to be because the doctrines are carried
along in the population.
The problem is,
what I hear you arguing and
you tell me if I have it wrong,
is that we should therefore expect,
uh,
the encoded metaphorical truths in
these religious traditions to be morally
right.
But there's nothing that actually says
it will be morally right because there
are metaphorical truth that
might in fact be reprehensible,
but nonetheless effective.
And so what I would argue,
the overarching point here
would be that you're right,
that the documents that contain these
descriptions of things are full of things
that are true in some sense that
is not literal scientific truth.
And our west up there,
their purpose,
what isn't true is that those
things are inherently up to date.
Um, and I wouldn't, okay.
I mean, first of all,
the first thing about that is
that a discussion like that,
and this is also what
happened with Sam Harris,
takes me to the very limits
of my intellectual ability.
And so even in discussing it, I'm going
to make all sorts of mistakes because,
because it's treacherous territory.
But I would say my understanding of the
great myths has that observation built
into it. So one of the archetypes is
that of the, of the tyrannical father,
which is the architect by the way,
that possesses the minds of people
who accused Western Society of being
patriarchal.
They're possessed by a singular archetype.
And that's the archetype
of the tyrannical father.
They don't see that there's a tyrannical
father and a wise king because there is,
that's, that's, you can't even
point that out. But anyways,
in the, in the oldest, in
some of our oldest stories,
there's a representation of the dead past.
So let me give you an example
that everyone knows about.
The Story of Pinocchio is the story
of the individualization of Pinocchio.
He starts out as a puppet.
He's a Marionette, he's a
wooden head, he's a liar.
And he's pulled by forces that he
does not understand. Right? Okay. So,
but he has a good father. That's
Japan. It went, so he's got a good,
and Japan have wishes that he
becomes a real individual. And so,
and he knows that that's an impossible,
what she wishes on a star,
that his son could become an actual
individual knowing full well that that's
unlikely and impossible. So
Japan, it was a good king. So,
but the story is also about Japan auto
because what happens is that when Japan
will loses Pinocchio,
loses his son, which will,
you could think about as the active
dynamic, attentive force of youth.
Then he ends up stultified
in the belly of a whale,
which is a symbol of chaos
at the bottom of the ocean.
And then Pinocchio has to rescue him.
So I would say there is an instantiation
of evolutionarily accumulated wisdom in
the great stories of the past,
but they're still dead
and it requires the union.
This is why in Christian theology,
the God had has tripartite structure.
This is part of the reason there's
God the father, but the father's dead.
The father was right a hundred years
ago or thousand years ago and is still
partly right, but he's dead.
He can't participate in the
updating of the process.
So you need an active force.
Now the act of force is the same thing
that generated those stories across time,
right? So it's, it's the same thing
except it's also alive in the present.
And so your moral duty, and
this is another thing that
happens in, in Pinocchio,
is to rescue your dead father
from the belly of the whale.
And that's partly what I'm trying to
do with these biblical lectures because
you're objection is correct.
The reason it's correct is because
even if the solution was correct,
the landscape has changed and it's changed
incrementally or in a revolutionary
way.
We don't know.
And so those old truths are at
best partial and at worst blind.
But that doesn't mean
you can just say like,
like Mao did during the
cultural revolution, we'll
let's just destroy the past.
It's like, no, that would
be like saying, well,
you don't need a body anymore because
your body is the collected wisdom of the
evolutionary process across three and a
half billion years. I absolutely agree.
Because the stories are not literal.
It's impossible to know whether they,
well not impossible,
but very difficult to know whether
or not the truth that is contained to
metaphorically is still relevant if it's
been inverted and it's now absolutely
false. Or, uh, so Carl Young
talked about this a lot. Hey, and,
and one of the things he said was
that your moral duty is to realize the
archetype in the, in the confines of
your own life. And so you say, well,
there's an archetype of perfection
that pervades the west. And for the,
for the sake of argument, I'm going
to call that Christ the Christ image.
It's something like that.
That's the archetypal image.
Now we have a story about what Christ's
historical life was like. Well,
well,
you can't have that life because you
would have had to be in the Middle East
2000 years ago.
That's not your life.
But what you can do is take the
archetype and you can manifest.
It was within the
confines of your own life,
and what that does is force you to undergo
the difficult process of updating the
ancient wisdom, and you don't just
forego it, you can't, or you can,
but you'll pay a massive price,
and part of that will be social
disintegration because it's, it's the,
the past is alive enough so that those
of us who inhabit its corpse aren't
clawing each other to death. Well, we're
feeding right? That's the critical issue.
Now,
it's not alive enough because the bloody
thing could fall apart at any moment,
and we need to be awake and alert in
order to keep it updated and maintained
well. Not only that, but they're,
the greatest hazards to us in the present
are only partially going to be dealt
with in these texts. And that's, that's
my biggest concern is that, you know,
if we take, uh, you know, Dawkins
dismissing religion as mind virus,
this was very dangerous
because it neglects the truth
that you're talking about
and it prevents us from
getting to a conversation in
which we can talk about the
fact that religious texts,
religions are not mind viruses,
they are adaptations to past environments.
They do contain a kind of truth that isn't
necessarily literal and is in general
not literal. Um, but none of them,
no ancient religion is up to date for
Google's algorithms being the hazard to
civilization.
That it probably is.
We need to figure out how to navigate
where the ancestral wisdom is simply not
up to the current challenge.
Let me modify that slightly because
I think it's true and not true.
The stories are, um, erroneous
in detail and write in pattern.
So for example,
there's an idea that one of the things
that the mythological hero does is stand
up against the tyranny of the state.
Now you don't have to specify the nature
of the tyranny of the state in order
for that to be a truth that's
applicable across different contexts.
I would say what's happened with the
great religious myths is that they've,
they operated level of obstruction
such that the abstract entities are
applicable in every single environment.
I'll give you an example of that.
It is extremely useful to represent the
phenomenology of your experience as a
domain of chaos and order that works
in every single environment for every
person. And so the domain of order
it, I can describe it technically,
you're in the domain of order.
When your actions produce the result
you desire and you're in the domain of
chaos when they don't. And then,
and then I could say, well,
your task is to straddle
the border between those two
domains because you don't
always want to be where everything that
you're doing is working because you
don't learn anything and you don't want
to be where nothing you're doing is
working because it's overwhelming.
You want to be stable and
dynamic at the same point.
And The Dallas do that very nicely
because they have a chaos order
conceptualization of the,
of the phenomenological landscape.
And their claim is the point of maximum
proper being is right at the center of
the border between chaos and order.
And I think that's true across contexts.
So I don't think that truth ages,
some of them don't know.
But the question really is one of,
at what point is there so much legacy
code that the taking the package is,
uh, is more harmful than it is
beneficial? And at what point are,
you know,
if God were writing today,
I'm pretty convinced the first
commandment would be thou shalt not enrich
uranium. It would make sense
as the number one commandment.
It's not there because you're any,
um,
wasn't a concept at the point that the
thing was written or was the hazard of
enriching it obvious.
And so
the fact that it isn't mentioned
tends to deemphasize it as a risk.
And so I guess the question
is, is it possible, I mean,
is it possible that by recognizing that
these traditions carry huge amounts of
ancestral wisdom forward,
but that that wisdom is certain to be
so incomplete that it doesn't address
modern questions that we can be liberated
to move forward and to honor those
traditions for bringing us here,
but to recognize that we actually have
to move forward with something more
potent and uptodate,
which is not,
not easy because you can't just take
the scientific truth of the moment and
implement a lot of it isn't even right.
Yeah.
It's also not that easy to
rewrite a fairy tale, you know?
And some of these fairy tales that people
are trying to rewrite in modern times
or perhaps 15,000 years
old and people think,
well we can just update that so that
the modern version will be better.
It turns out that that's very, very
difficult. And there's another,
I'm going to play devil's advocate
against my own position here. You know,
cause I say,
well the religious texts in code profound
and evolutionarily determined truths
that are universal. Okay. Which
religious texts, right? Because,
well because you might say,
well all of them,
but then that means that obscures
the important differences between the
traditions. And I'm by no means
certain that all of them do. You know?
So I'm going to stick my neck
way the hell out because why not?
It isn't obvious to me
that Islam does because I,
it's very difficult for me to see that
the totalizing nature of Islam doesn't
make it unique among religions. So
now good. So while there's that old,
if you don't mind, but it isn't
the issue using the word truth.
Cause we can say true, we could use
tradition and wisdom and were okay,
but as soon as we start saying truth,
then then we run into problems. I mean,
and even when you're talking about
porcupines where you're talking about
w what did you say? Metaphorical
truth versus, look, it's not true.
It's real simple.
Just don't go near the porcupine teach.
The kid did not go near the porcupine
because porcupine quills are dangerous.
They get stuck in you.
The really dangerous can they throw it at,
you know they cannot,
but just stay clear of them because you
don't want them to somehow know they get
in touch with your body.
There's no truth in that.
They can throw their quills at you.
You benefit from being particularly
aware of the dangers of their quills.
But if you tell a kid that they can throw
their quills and so therefore the kid
stays clear of him.
Here's a faulty assumption in his head,
you're lying to them for their own
protection and that's not good.
I wouldn't do it.
I think the same thing can be said of
everything happens for a reason. Well,
here's the problem. We don't know
if everything happens for a reason.
Maybe when you die you go to some
auditing room and they go, well, you know,
it's all just a part of some gigantic
algorithm that you, impossible.
It's impossible for you to understand
duty or limited processing power of the
human brain.
You're dealing with some Semyon sort of
a complex geometry that's really just
designed to keep your body moving and
keep you alive and spread your genetics so
that you can eventually evolve
to the point when you were a god.
Well, first of all, I, I have kids.
I wouldn't tell him that a porcupine.
I'm sure you wouldn't. But how, but why
use the word truth though? Because, well,
the question is why do people tell you
that a porcupine can throw its quilts?
I don't think they do. Oh,
they do. Well, if they do,
they don't know any
better or they're liars.
And so all I'm saying is that actually
is likely to be the product of selection.
In other words,
that those people who had encoded that
they do throw their quills have an
advantage.
It's not the way I wouldn't do it and
for exactly the reason that you point out
which is if you give a child
the wrong model of a porcupine,
I don't know whether a porcupine is
liable to be the gateway to some more
important question, but if it were,
you've just steered the kid wrong.
Here's part of the problem, and this is
part of this is a really big problem.
There's two things I guess that were
brought up by what you described in the
first is the terminology of truth.
Now Harris,
his claim with regards to my utilization
of truth was that I was absconding with
the definition of truth
and it false matter,
but he was wrong because the idea of
truth is much older than the idea of
objective truth and the original
notion of truth wasn't objective. True.
It was like the Arrow flies
straight and true. Right?
It had meant something like reliably,
reliably on its way to the appropriate
destination, something like that.
And when Christ said,
I am the truth and the way what I
can remember [inaudible] yes, yes.
The truth he was talking about
wasn't an objective truth.
So Sam's idea that I had somehow taken
the idea of truth that was actually
objective all along and done something
crooked with it is just wrong. It's wrong.
Well, there's so truth can have
multiple definitions. That's the issue.
And that's exactly what we're, what we're
trying to get at here is like there's,
to me, there's two kinds of
truth and, and they may be,
they may be commensurate, you may be
able to stack them on top of one another,
but now and then they dissociate.
And, and this is actually what, what,
what Brett was referring to as well.
So,
so in this is where it gets so
complicated that I can barely manage it.
There's a, there's the truth that manifest
itself in the manner in which you act.
And there's the truth that manifest itself
as a representation of the objective
world.
And sometimes both those truths are
stacked on top of each other and sometimes
they're not.
So like I could give you a piece of wisdom
that would work well if you acted it
out. That carried within it an inaccurate
representation of part of the objective
world. And you could say, well,
maybe that's actually the case with the
biblical stories because if you read
them as science,
they don't read well.
So let's take malaria as a good example.
Malaria,
the root of the word is
mal area, bad air, right?
Malaria is not transmitted by bad air.
It's transmitted by mosquitoes that live
in places where you might think the air
is bad. So the point is, it's part of the
way there and that's, that's a good one.
And then that,
and that also gets,
see there's another weird distinction
here and that I was trying to draw it with
Sam,
but that's a really tricky one.
And we ordered in because we
started to talk about pragmatism,
but there's also something like the
truth of a description and the truth of a
tool. And my sense is that people's
fundamental truths are tool.
Like we use them to function properly
in the world. And you could say, well,
a sharp ax is more true than a doll acts.
And actually you can use the word
true in that sense that actually isn't
appropriate appropriate
use of the word there.
There are tool truth and there are
objective factors now and in the optimal
circumstance those map onto each other
but we're not smart enough often to make
the map onto each other because we just
don't know enough and there are lots of
truths that we have that portray the
objective world improperly that are still
true.
Is this problem using the term true when
sometimes you should use the term fact
like like yes,
one plus one is two that is a fact.
One plus one is two is also true.
You throw some water on a match that is
and it'll go out. That's a fact. Yes.
Well,
as I see it,
at least there is this overarching truth,
the one that Sam Harris was pointing to,
the one I think you're pointing to
also and the one I I'm imagining we all
subscribe to,
right there is the testable truth that
reveals itself in the laboratory or in a
careful experiment in the field and
that really is the top level of truth.
But then there are the
truths you can't speak yet.
So let's take the word filth from uh,
from the Old Testament. Okay?
Filth means shit, right?
You're not supposed to shit in camp
because God finds it offensive.
Now the problem is the germ theory of
disease doesn't come about for thousands
of years after that truth was written.
That truth keeps you from infecting people
long before you can ever explain that
there are microbes that grow in human
shit that are a particular danger to your
population.
So the point is,
would you rather be held back to the
place where you can actually describe the,
the literal underpinnings
of what's going on?
Or do you want to be liberated to say
something that actually results in a,
an improvement in health before,
you know,
literally thousands of years
before anybody had any idea
that it was microbes at
the root of this, you
need to figure out. So,
so an elaboration of that
would be something like
human beings needed to figure
out how to act without dying before
they could understand the nature of the
world well enough to justify
that. Right? And you be,
be crazy now that we do have
the germ theory of disease to,
to amplify that original crude version
of the truth or that crude approximation
of what you need to believe
in order to behave safely.
There's no reason for that truth
to, to be promoted. In fact,
you don't hear people describing this part
of uh, the, the old testament anymore.
It's not relevant,
right?
This is probably all wad
dietary restrictions were in
the old testament as well.
Shellfish, red tide,
uh, eating pigs trick.
Gnosis there's a lot of lot of issues
that go along with that. Right?
Well there is some intermingling perhaps
of hygienic concerns with also the
desire for the groups to distinguish
themselves from other groups. Right?
Cause you can, you can unite your group
quite tightly by dietary restrictions. So,
um, back to your point about
terminology, you know, we could,
we could do something like fact and
wisdom, you know, you say truth.
That's the overarching category.
And then that divides into fact and
wisdom and what you want optimally as you
want the facts and the wisdom to be one
on one to one. But often they're not.
And if you find wisdom where
the facts aren't laid right out,
you don't just get to
throw away the wisdom,
which is what I think happens in the
case of people like Dawkins and Harrison
Harris makes another sleight of hand move,
which I don't like,
which is that he thinks so let's say,
except for just a second,
the wisdom fact distinction.
He would say, well,
the fact is the thing and the wisdom
is a second order derivation of that.
You can ground the wisdom in the fact,
and I don't believe that.
And I don't think that he has any,
I don't think that he has any
real justification for that claim.
And this is something I
never thought you would,
even by grounding the wisdom in the Fed
thinks if you know the facts clearly
enough, you'll know how to act well.
That's not necessarily true. Right? Well,
there's a huge as ways to act with
that are within your best interest.
And then there's ways to act that are
within the interest of all the people
around you've been might not
serve you that well. Well,
there's also a addiction is
where ethics come, right?
The consequences are delayed for some
number of generations. Shorter. Yes.
Well that's a big problem.
And so,
so Sam acts as if the process of Mac
mapping facts onto action is simple.
If we just got the facts right but,
but it's the weakest part of his argument
and we never ever got to that for a
variety of reasons.
But part of the reason it's weak is okay,
while there's like an infinite
number of facts, man, which,
so let's say you're standing in front of
a field and you're looking at the field,
the field does not tell
you how to walk through it.
There's a million ways through the field
and no matter how many facts about the
field you aggregate,
you're not going to be able to determine
the appropriate path by aggregating
those fats. So that's, and that,
that's a problem that I don't think Sam
is willing to take seriously and well,
well I think there, there are two
problems tangled up here. One of them is,
there's a question of are
is one individual supposed
to have all of the facts?
And navigate based on on that sort of
the rationality community version of
things or the,
you know,
the practical truth is we can't
all be experts in everything.
And so we have to go along with,
you know,
guides to our behavior that are
approximate and that that's inherent.
And then there's a question
about civilization.
Civilization should be guided by our best
understanding of what's actually true,
but with an understanding that we don't
have a complete map of a lot of stuff.
And so I think what you're pointing at
is that there is wisdom that has been
handed to us that is not such
that we can just simply say, oh,
here's the nugget at the center of it and
we need to preserve that thing because
we don't necessarily know what it's
doing now, which is, you know, that's,
this is dangerous because some of what
it's doing may not be acceptable. Well,
and think about, let's look at the
wisdom end of things for a minute.
And you talked,
you alluded a little earlier too,
like iterations and about the fact that
things are reiterated across time and
that's something that works now might
fail dreadfully in a month or two months.
So, so here's, here's what
something has to be like to be wise,
let's say, well first of all, um,
let's say it would be good if it
was a new accordance with the facts,
but we'll leave that aside for now.
It has to work.
If you operate according to the
wisdom principal, whatever it is,
it has to work in the world.
But then it has to work in a world
that allows you to maintain your
relationships with people
in the world, right? So,
so it's all of a sudden this wisdom
thing is something that's not only
constrained by,
let's call it objective reality,
but it's constrained by the
necessity of a social contract,
a functional social contract.
So you're only able to,
you're only allowed to put forward actions
in the world that would be of benefit
to you if they simultaneously don't
undermine the structure within which you
live. Okay. And then there's a game
theory element to that, which is, well,
if it's wise,
then it works in the world.
So that'd be the constraint
of objective reality.
But then it works for you now and the you,
that'll be in a week and the you that
will be in a month and it works for you
and your family and it works for
you and your family and society.
And it works in a way that those things
all line up to be iterated across time.
And so this,
this is actually the also the solution
is I'd really like to hear what you think
about this. I think this is the solution
to the postmodern conundrum because the
postmodernists, bless their hearts.
So we'll give the devil his due say,
well,
the problem is there's an infinite number
of interpretations of a finite set of
facts. And the right
response to that is, oh,
that's true. That's true, that's not good.
And that's why the postmodern to say,
well, you can't agree on a
canonical interpretation of
great piece of literature
because the number of potential
interpretations are infinite.
And so then they say, well, why should
we settle on any one interpretation that,
why should we privilege one over
another? And then they say, well,
that's all power games. And so that's
you. You got to take that seriously.
But what they missed,
and this is a big deal,
it's a big deal I think is this idea of,
of ethical constraint. It's like, yes,
there's a landscape of potentially
infinite interpretations,
but hardly any of them will
work in the real world.
And hardly any of them will work in the
real world in a way that doesn't get you
killed by other people or do mew because
of your own stupidity to failure across
time. And so the landscape of
interpretation has almost infinite.
But the landscape of
applicable interpretation,
functional interpretation
is unbelievably constrained.
And I think that constraint system
is what we regard as ethics.
It's something like that.
Well, at some level, um,
stories continue through
time for a reason. You know,
good stories continue for a long,
you know,
the Odyssey is with us
for some reason and we,
so there is a scientific reason or
scientifically investigated [inaudible]
reason why the Odyssey has been durable.
We may not know it,
but in principle it's a question
you could investigate. Um,
so I guess at the end of the day,
the problem with the postmodernists
is that they have a point.
The point is perception gets in the way
of anything we wished to do objectively,
but that point only takes you so far.
And uh,
that's why they turned to
Marxism as far as I can tell,
because what happens with the
postmodernist as they say, oh,
there's an infinite
number of interpretations.
And then the human part of them goes,
okay,
well what am I supposed to do next?
Then since there's an infinite number
of choices and the postmodernist says,
well, my theory can't account for that.
And then they say, well, back to Marxism.
And so that's why I think there's
this unholy alliance between the
postmodernists and the neo Marxist
just because postmodernism is a,
is a dead end from the
perspective of applicable wisdom.
It leaves you bereft and nihilistic.
And that's not good because people
can't exist without a purpose.
And so they sneak the Marxism
through the back door and,
and jump into this power landscape for
the reasons that we discussed earlier.
Really think that it's because of
an infinite number of possibilities
interpretating things because I've
always felt that it was really just a
response to capitalism.
They like that they feel that capitalism
is a very negative aspect of our
culture and society and that there's
gotta be some sort of an alternative
Marxism.
Is it clearly defined alternative that
other people have subscribed to in the
past?
You could point to it.
It's a structure that's already there
already set up and it's romanticized and I
think they adopted for that reason because
it has the socialist aspects attached
to it.
And they looked at socialism as it's
some sort of a thing that a re regarding
equality and uh, you know, it's some
sort of an egalitarian yep. Approach.
Well it's okay.
So we'd have to take two things apart.
We'd have to take Marxism slash neo,
Marxist,
Marxism and postmodernism apart.
So we could do that historically.
And I would say that although there
is a reason for postmodernism,
which is the reason we just discussed,
that the landscape,
the infinite landscape of interpretation
problem, it's a real problem.
If you look at it historically,
postmodernism actually
grew out of Marxism.
And so what,
what happened is that the
Marxists laid out there their,
their theory about the human social
environment being composed of a power
struggle between the privileged
and the underprivileged, right?
The rich and the poor and
in its initial phases.
And that's a story that's partially
true and it's got a lot of motive power.
Like the motive power is the romantic
motive power that you just described.
I get to be on this side of the oppressed.
I get to be a war.
You're for what's right.
There's the resentment element,
which is that son of a
bitch has more than me,
so let's cut them off at the knees,
which manifested itself
brutally in the Soviet Union.
And then there's the ideological totality
issue which gives people a sense of
security.
That took a vicious hit by,
by the late 1960s because
the murderousness of Marxism
had been clearly laid out
as a doctrine and that opened the
door to this move by by mostly French
intellectuals to to develop the postmodern
philosophy which has these advantages
which we described,
but but also to use that as a a
screaming tactic for allowing Marxism to
transform into identity politics.
And so like it's hard to disentangle
all the motivations that are going on in
there,
but there's something about it that's
that's truly intellectually pathological
because you don't get to be a
postmodernist and a Marxist.
You actually technically cannot be
both of those things at the same time.
And the fact that most people are both
of those things at an at the same time
raises the specter of just
exactly what their motivation is.
And then I would say it's this
resentment driven anti-capitalism.
There's reasons to criticize capitalism,
obviously,
but it's this underground resentment
driven anti-capitalism that I think is one
of the fundamental motivators.